Mike is not sure how to solve the example of 189 + 608.
The same as the 189 + 608 operation
Let's help Mike by choosing the collection task.
Let's look at these choices.
Starting with the first selection,
in fact, all these choices begin with a hundredths,
Each of them has one hundred, but where do we see one hundredths here?
There are 189 numbers on the floor, 1 figure.
This figure here is a hundred, that is, 100 units.
In addition, all other options have six hundred.
6 hundredths, 6 hundredths, so what do we get?
The number 608 is 6 on the floor,
therefore, here is 6 figures representing 6 hundredths.
Thus, we learned that 1 hundredth and 6 hundredths have come.
then there are 8 decimal places in each of them,
all of them are identical.
therefore, they have 8, 8, 8 and 8 decimal places.
how are they
The figure of 189 is 8 digits on the floor,
where it refers to eighteen.
8 decimal, and then what are you here?
Here are some minor changes already made.
Let's go one by one.
The next nine are loneliness.
9 loneliness, where do we get them?
189, 9 digits are on the floor alone.
in this case, it is desirable to mark 9 here.
and finally, here 8 alone
and 8 alone, how do we get them?
608, 8 digits are on the solitude floor,
where the figure is loneliness. and when it is given, everything appears in the order.
But here you can think of a moment.
"Well, we have all considered these figures,
0 except why we did not take it into account.
Why is there 0 in the field of decimal?
Hence, 0 here simply has 0 decimal function,
which means zero.
it does not affect the price of anything.
the first one is the same.
as in the case of an initial baseline.
if we want to know which of the other data is incorrect,
this is 8 times twofold, but we have one ten.
Here we have a tenth of ten, which is on the 8th floor.
In this case, "solitude" should be written here.
and we have eight singles.
but here, in fact, is solitude.
This is not a decimal, where "solitude" should be mentioned.
That's why we will not accept these two.
Let's solve one or more similar examples.
Which is the collection matter
525 + 379 operation is the same?
Let's read:
Here are hundreds of floors on the floor 5 figures,
which means 500 numbers.
then there are 3 figures on the floor floor.
in this case + 300,
then, there are 2 digits on the ground floor,
ultimately, two are 10 or 20,
After that, the figure on the floor is 7.
in this case, + 70, and, ultimately, but not the least
We see the figure 5 on the floor, which means 5 digits.
then on the solitude floor 9
Will indicate the figure 9.
in this case, which of these data is
is the same as what I wrote first?
500 + 300, 500 or 300 are not marked on this first.
in this case we do not count it.
500 + 300 + 20 + 70 + 5 +9,
This is exactly the same thing as I wrote a note.
This latter is not appropriate because 9 instead of 9 is marked,
then 5 and then 70 instead of 70.
The figure 7 had to be marked on the floor, not on the floor alone.
We do not just register it.